SHIGERU MIYAGAWA: So I developed
the MOOC Visualizing Japan,
which is an MITx HarvardX joint
project with John Dower of MIT,
Annie Gordon of
Harvard, and also
Gennifer Weisenfeld of Duke.
I incorporated the MOOC material
into my residential class
in 2014, and it
changed everything.
It changed literally everything.
And I continued to use it right
up until my last offering,
which was fall of 2016.
Before 2014, it was a
very traditional class
with lectures, PowerPoints,
and a little bit
of student discussion.
When I incorporated the
MOOC material in 2014,
I didn't anticipate
any major changes.
I simply said,
why don't you look
at these video lectures
we just produced
and see what you think,
and think about them?
And what I realized
right away was
that students would
come into class,
and they would have
a lot of knowledge,
which was not the case before.
So I would ask, so when
did Perry come to Japan?
1853.
When did Meiji era begin?
1868.
Why did it begin?
Blah, blah.
So, my goodness.
I had a whole set of
PowerPoints which I had
created from years of teaching.
I did not show a
single PowerPoint.
For 70 minutes, I just
asked them questions, just
to see if I can find something
that they didn't know.
They knew the whole thing.
And I said, gee,
this is different.
And without realizing it--
I didn't even know what
a flipped class was--
I just did a flipped class.
I did not lecture
for a single minute.
It was just question,
answer, discussion,
posing deeper questions
for students to discuss.
And I was absolutely,
absolutely stunned
that just in this one
class, the way I teach
changed fundamentally.
So by having flipped the class,
one big concrete thing that
came out of it--
this is MIT.
So one of the
students was actually
getting some data on this.
So there were a
couple times when
I had a traditional
lecture class,
because I had to do something.
And this student timed me.
And she found that I was
speaking 80%, students 20%,
which for a traditional
lecture class, that's not bad.
And then so she told me that.
And I said, well, look.
Why don't you do the same thing
when we do the discussion?
So she did that, and she
found that it was 50-50.
And qualitatively, it's
just completely different,
completely different.
I remember we had
a bunch of visitors
from Japan the second
week of the class.
And I was doing the
interactive style.
And they came up to me and said,
so how many months have you
been teaching this class?
I said, two weeks.
They are like, it's
quite remarkable.
I mean, just the sheer amount
of knowledge the students gain
from this new way of
teaching you cannot compare
to the previous.
We like to lecture.
We all like to lecture.
And I miss lecturing.
A lot of faculty members
who flip class tell me this.
In their quiet moment in
the corner of their room,
they whisper, I miss lecturing.
But we all know that
this flipping class makes
it so much more effective.
What's really important is to
have good material for students
to study ahead of class, and
I strongly recommend video.
Video is a very rich
source of knowledge.
And if you combine
that with reading,
you'll be amazed at how much
students bring into class.
And as one of my
colleagues, Rhonda Gibson,
who has flipped her
materials class has said,
the reason why flipped
class is so effective
is the students touch the
same material several times.
Once when they viewing it
before coming to class,
and second time when
we're discussing it,
and third time when they do
a piece that's based on it.
That's why it's so effective.
Yeah.
I think lecturing is going to
go the wayside of blackboards.